MAV choix de monsieur commence comme une
banale discussion entre patri secrétaire
général de l'UM et le nouveau déput de
Ly le mot est lâché dans le Petit
Larousse femme dévergondé de mauvaise
vie gar et vis
anneentre et
de la soirée alors que la séquence tour
boucle sur Internet Patrick dejan
appelle Anne Marie comparen pour
s'excuser elle réclame alors des excus
publi bon je vais essayer Degen royale
Jean-Pierre affarin ce matin le
téléphone d'anne-mie Comparini ne cesse
de
sonner notre
pays a besoin au 21e siècle d'avoir une
culture politique du 21e siècle moderne
c'est-àdire qu'il y ait du du respect de
la classe politique du respect des élus
U ou des élus
UE solidarité et indignation des femmes
du gouvernement il est pas tolérable on
puisse qualifier femme politique ou pas
d'ailleurs utiliser ce type de propos le
mot est inqualifiable s'adressant à une
femme et d'autant plus que c'est une
adversaire politique ou une concurrente
on lui doit d'autant plus le
respect au même moment Patrick deedjan
préside le conseil général des haut de
scè l'interruption de séance n'était pas
prévu le respect est très important et
c'est pour ça que j'ai commis une erreur
et c'est pour ça que je l'ai regretté et
c'est pour ça que j'ai présenté des
excuses à Annemie comp c'est une
faute l'affaire de la presque une
affaire d'état à son tour Nicolas
Sarkozi
intervient c'est pas des façons de
parler aux femmes et à qui que ce soit
un dossier de plus pour Nicolas SAR
apprendre les bonnes manières
à